hello everybody my name is markiplier
and this is another V log to give you
guys an update on what's going on with
the channel and answer some questions
that you guys asked in the last V log
I'm first off the November donation
drive was incredibly successful you guys
helped us raise money for a special
project that we were talking about and
you guys really really came through for
us because we met our goal we even
exceeded it by a little bit and this
means that Wade and I can move forward
with them some special stuff that we
have in store for you that I'm actually
going to tell you about because I've
already told people about it on the
livestream this weekend and I'm really
excited for it because we raise money to
buy new camera equipment and I think
we're going to get a Canon 5d for a new
camera and some audio recording
equipment green screens stuff like that
because we want to be able to do better
sketch comedy videos and this is our big
plan that we got for it we're going to
Wade and I is the weed that I'm talking
about Wade and I are going to be
starting a new channel called markiplier
TV and what this channel is all about is
about us doing weekly sketch comedy
videos I think I've told a lot of people
you know very often that one of my
biggest inspirations is Freddie Wong
because um his method for making unique
original content and stuff like that
every single week is amazing to me and
something that I wanted to do before I
even got into Let's Plays so the idea of
being able to finally do that as you
know it's it's my dream it's exactly
what I wanted to do when I got on no
YouTube I never wanted to start out with
Let's Plays but I'm not gonna stop by
any means if any of you are worried then
I'm gonna stop doing Let's Plays in
favor of this no this this is just a
something on top of what we already have
so you've already got the videos that I
release here mostly horror stuff and
then Wade and I will be doing sketch
comedy videos every single week starting
sometime and we're hoping to start early
the or early next year probably in
January
February whenever we can get our new
house set up and all the stuff that we
need and all I'll basically get our
friends to exploit them for free
cameraman and special effects and you
know bad guys to shoot at or whatever
whatever we need but we've got a lot of
stuff planned and it should be a lot of
fun to do and hopefully you guys will
find it entertaining if you like the
fall of Slenderman doll which you can
find here if if you're curious of what
we can do as far as sketch comedy and
VFX and we'll not really VFX but you
know just making our own actual original
content would be nice so that is
something that we're going to be looking
forward to also there is a charity
livestream at some point this month I'm
thinking I'm shooting for December 22nd
which is a Saturday if not then we'll
work it out as we get closer to it but I
know that we are doing a charity
livestream this month once again I don't
know the charity that we're going for we
might do a charity that relates to one
of my friends who had to get a organ
donation a kidney transplant he's a good
friend of mine and he suggested that we
do that so he might be the inspiration
and he might be there and he's a cool
guy so you might you might enjoy
watching in the live stream and we will
be playing different games in Minecraft
probably so also um if you guys will
there are gonna be many live streams
this month besides the charity one but
if you guys just want to stop by the
twitch channel which is in the
description below you can actually catch
me in the chat because I've started
using that as my personal chat room so
if you ever want to get in contact with
me directly I have my chat window up
anytime that I'm on the computer it's up
I may not always be there to respond
because I'm working on the projects or
I'm I'm out of out of the house and you
know you can't get to me but there are
other people to chat there regularly now
a good group of 10 or so pop in every
day so it's nice to be able to tap
chattin joke around with them and also
I've toned moobot down so if you guys
want to post links you can while it's
open so but don't abuse it because there
are moderators and
watching so if you abused it I will turn
move back on and he will bust your ass
okay so that's that so please stop by
the twitch chat anytime you want chat
with me you can get in contact with me
you can know what I'm not - and
sometimes tell them what I'm what video
I'm about to release before they release
it so there's no point not going alright
so that some questions where do you see
yourself and your channel a year from
now tortilla boy 97 um a year from now
would be December of next year my goal
is hit on a thousand subscribers by June
of next year so another six months from
then I don't know hopefully I'll be
knee-deep in the I'll get a lot of good
experience in on the sketch comedy
channel and the VFX videos what we're
gonna make so hopefully I'll be well
entrenched in that and maybe you know by
then maybe I'll have an equal number of
subscribers to my let's play channel but
who knows you never know how those
things go I can only hope for the best
note that you guys like it and share the
videos but you know I'm still gonna be
doing the same thing hopefully just with
two more subscribers so that's all
there's mark why are you so wordly
wordly worldly it's rare it seems rare
or a youtuber to be so open and
forthright about such personal things
also why dis make me love you more give
this man a hug yo sincerely dr.
eisenhower well thank you doctor you're
educated opinion and always welcome on
my channel do you know the only way to
get more worldly I guess
if anything if I I'm understanding your
definition of worldly correctly it's
just uh understand the world more and
the only way you can do that is by
trying to learn everyday and I've always
advocated this I advocate on the life
term this weekend read read that's all
you need to do you know get opinions
from as many sources as you can get an
idea it craft your idea of the world
from as many viewpoints as possible
because if you just do it from one
viewpoint the world is flat and everyone
knows what the people who think the
world is flat are like
they're morons so even if you only get a
few opinions of the world you start to
develop the whole picture like you can
only really appreciate people and
humanity if you get knee-deep in it and
you experience it and you know about it
so I've always said don't talk about
anything that you don't know about and
you know that way you won't make you you
won't make an ass out of yourself
basically that's how you get more
worldly and as far as a hug okay I did
everyone got a bonus huh
okay yo mama one two three seven seven
asks have you heard about Alan Wake yes
I've actually played it and I stopped
halfway through well not on the computer
I played on the Xbox and I stopped
halfway through because I got bored
okay what is your best sexy voice MCR
girl oh he's going oh I like your little
pants huh
dear mark can you tell us why you're so
exist with that pink mustache you mean
this thing was dad aha uh I don't know
it's just I've always had this lying
around I bought this I bought this like
back in February of last year as one of
the props that I originally bought
because I thought I was going to start
my youtube career with doing sketch
comedy videos so I wanted to have as
many problems as possible so I bought a
bunch of mustaches and this one I never
had a use for it was always staring me
at me in the face and I just randomly
picked it out to make Worf stache and so
I don't know I I kind of like I like it
a lot of it's it's it's hilarious in my
opinion bright not funny to other people
as it is to my butt every time I put a
show on I begin to talk as Worf - died
anyone I I'm not obsessed with it but I
just like it a lot it's also my new my
new - subscribe channel thing subscribe
today
whoa I don't know why that makes me
laugh I'm probably an idiot for thinking
that's funny okay
Jana Cabrera asks are you currently in a
relationship if not are you lurking
lurking Lukey um actually that that's
kind of bit of weird rumor that's
speculating that I'm actually in a
relationship and then I'm dating someone
at University of Cincinnati I'm not I'm
not in a relationship not that I know of
anyway unless one of you are gonna sneak
up behind me and just jump me in an
alley I don't think that I'm in a
relationship in fact I'm not I'm gonna
explicitly say that I'm not marrying no
I'm not
I'm not as far as looking I'm not really
looking right now because I'm
exceptionally busy and I'm with the new
channel that's coming up when I'm doing
a lot of prep work I got at each weight
a bunch of stuff about video editing
I've got to jump around everywhere I've
got friends they need my help at the
moment and I've got a lot of stuff on my
plate but I don't really have time for a
relationship and I've had my share and
I've had my fill and I I prefer to be
single at the moment unless one of you
out there can convince me otherwise
oh yeah how come you don't live stream
on YouTube ass G oh six six six
I don't live stream on YouTube because
YouTube live stream functionality is not
optimal it does not I mean it allows for
screen sharing and whatnot but it does
not allow for a good game live streaming
now if it did I might be inclined to use
it because obviously I have more
subscribers on YouTube than I do on
Twitch and there's more opportunities
for people to watch it than on Twitch
not that there's anything wrong switch I
just got partnered on twitch so I'm
trying to have to bad-mouth them but not
that there's anything wrong with it
explicitly it's just said you know it's
not as easy to do or as easy for you
guys to do or watch or look at so until
they improve it I'm not gonna visit it
again as he mark how are you able to
play all these horror games and not be
scared enough to quit well I mean a lot
of its practice and a lot of its you
know I kind of have a dedication to not
quit I mean I kind of quit that SCP
video but I was close to the end so I
felt like I could escape I was closing
the end of the video so I could smell
like I could escape but you know they it
is scary
but that's part of the fun I mean you do
this and it's really fun to be able to
do these videos for you and record
videos like this and just have a blast
at it it's it it's a lot of fun to me
it's probably the most fun I could ever
met
doing you know for a paycheck it's it's
just it's just awesome to be able to do
this and so I'm grateful that I can so
thank you all for watching because
without you I wouldn't do this I would
be too scared if I didn't have an
audience watching and definitely I
wouldn't be able to do it so thank you
all and that's all the questions I have
time for now it's already 12 minutes in
and I've been rambling way too long so
thank you all so much for watching I'm
just gonna leave on this I need your
help that's what I need that's what I'm
talking about
I need your help I want to get I want to
do more like quirky quirky little video
game stuff that me playing Mario and
Robot Unicorn Attack and clop kind of
inspired me that there are a lot of
little games out there that not many
people know about well not those Mario
maybe but not the other ones but there
are little games out there little Indian
games Indian indie games that I would be
very much inclined to play so if you
guys have an idea of a small indie game
quirky or whatnot
doesn't have to be horror at all maybe a
flash game maybe just some game that
some guy made if you got an idea for one
let me know in the comments below I
would really like to know it and just
tell me what to Google so that I know
how to find it correctly because
sometimes if people say to shout out a
name and I have no idea where to find it
so just let me know in the comments
below and also if you have questions
that I want to answer
make them creative don't just make them
things about my life being really
creative creative questions the more
creative the more inclined I am to
answer it so write those in the comments
below as well and thank you all so much
for watching as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye